you guys hear me
yes sir
all right cool need your steam code sir
they uh everybody's getting a little
nervous
yeah the steam friend code thing
uh yeah by the way you guys are muted
but we're livestreaming but you're good
i just want to let you know
you mute it yeah just give it a heads up
because i had to do like a a pre-rolling
stream
to get going
[Laughter]
hold on let me talk to the people while
you do that
yeah testing testing
what is going on people
yes yes we are live hella spooked what's
going on man slow mo what's going on
chilling chilling just getting things
going do a little audio test pre-stream
for the iron challenge you know what i'm
saying we got some
lords in the building already yeah lords
on a saturday real quick
um let's do a mic check let me know how
the music sounds hr obama what's going
on i've seen a minute what's going on
slow
um let me know how my volumes sound in
relationship to this music in the back
you are listening to the sweet tunes of
iron harvest this is the soundtrack
going on i appreciate you bro
you gonna stop saying that i still can't
hear you cockney
i like that's a good joke it's a good
joke how am i in relation to the music
do i sound all right
let me know about that and then i'm
gonna unmute the guys real quick
we got um the lords in the realm
you know what i'm saying so we got one
half of the iron challenge
which is you know what i'm saying lord
addict
and of course lord p and the man you
know as
undead three xvi lord of lords of
gaming.net
editor assistant editor so i want
actually let me get um undead talk to
the people real quick
can everybody hear me all right i'm
coming through the clear baby
no doubt and of course talk to the
people right quick what's going on you
guys this is about to be very quick
are you trying to say we got we getting
smoked no
maybe i'm saying we bout to smoke them
that's what i'm talking about
all right so the music is a little loud
that's what slo-mo says
all right so i can turn that down a
little bit i'm sorry we can do that
all right let me know how it is now slow
i would appreciate that petey will be
coming soon
and i am going to probably mute for a
minute
and then i'll come right back but just
tell me how that music is sounding in
relationship
to our voices hr obama says attic tetris
baby tetris
music was a little loud thank you okay
thank you all right cool cool slow mo
you know you know the pain of live
streaming and hosting i appreciate you
brother
yeah man so just chill out we will be
there um
gonna actually mute the music for a bit
and then we'll become a come right back
oh before i do that actually actually
shout out to keith what's up i gotta eat
with the knowledge of super chat master
clowns x3 with the 20
super chat wow pay my respect and
admiration have
a good one thank you yeah so we go get
ready for the the challenge and we'll
see you out a bit
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right and we are live my check might
check we are in the realm of the iron
challenge and this is the iron
lords of the realm versus the iron
harvest developers the beautiful king
art games
and of course sir toby himself so let's
get into these introductions
real quick let's start with the man
you've probably seen on iron lord
podcast a few times
the legendary sir tell me talk to the
people sir
uh yeah hello ladies and gentlemen uh
ladies and lords it's me again toby but
this time not for kingdom come
deliverance but for iron harvest 1920
plus and
of course it's a huge honor to be with
the iron lords of gaming
and to kick some
[Music]
right ass right so we're gonna get into
it and of course we have
elliot can you please mention to the
people who you are your role
king arts absolutely hi there i'm elliot
i
am one of the developers particularly
one of the game designers on iron
harvest
and uh yeah i'm very happy to be here
and i'm looking forward to kicking
your ass here wow they're spicy early
i love it i love it a lot of talk from
the people that make the game
get your stream going on my side it says
starting suits i said you know all right
well i was just waiting for the actual
home okay don't worry no worries and
of course we have one more gentleman
from the team
let me call you lord will
[Music]
for this wonderful game um the iron
doctor if you see my name around discord
and stuff
i'm the go-to guy for all your little
questions about how to get stuff done
yes um and if i don't know anything
elliot will know it um
we'll rely on it yeah it's an absolute
pleasure to be here and i'm looking
forward to keeping some neck pass
oh this is awesome this is awesome
but they're shiny and they're metal and
it's going to hurt
there we go and of course the challenges
the what are we going to call this with
the irresistible frost versus the
immovable object
and here is the irresistible force lords
of gaming and
our ilps own my co-host with the
co-boast
lord addict how we doing sir doing
pretty good uh know i'm about to
pretty much have an auto l but uh you
know
this is the first time man it's
confident i'm just being realistic
just being realistic i think we all know
how this is gonna go down
hey we gotta we got a challenge we're
gonna put up a good fight but
if if we somehow win i will never let
you live this game
exactly exactly and of course we have
again lords of gaming.net own and of
course
member of the stream team himself making
putting himself here through outstanding
circumstances this man has a power
outage in his area and he's still on the
stream
my man how we doing sir
i'm pretty good uh you know trying to do
this in a basement in darkness on some
pro laptop on generators but you know
i'm ready to have some good times have
some fun you know i'm ready to
you know automatically lose a little bit
but you know we're gonna have a good
time doing it so
all right well adele and the final
challenger
lords of gaming.net's own assistant
editor and host
of the gaming perspective my man lord
undead 3 xvi what's going on oh well i'm
here and i'm the only one that's
apparently not ready to roll over and
die so let's go
it's not about rolling over and dying
it's about keeping my expectations
okay
i have about nine to ten games in here
but that don't touch everyone else
so let's get to it guys so i'm gonna
kick it over to elliot
and uh let's get the festivities started
toby as well
okay so we are right now in the main
menu which is already good so let me
just
change my screen so everyone can see
what they're supposed to see is
everything
okay so as always if there's any
connectivity issue or sound or whatever
just let me know and eventually we can
do something
anyway gentlemen we are ready for a
three versus three on the
restless woods map it's the biggest map
we have right now
yeah what's funny toby i i've picked
i've picked this map apart because i
knew this is the only map we would be
able to play
so okay so so i hear big words okay okay
okay
that's good that's good that's good um
and as you can see
my iron hands my sexy dudes are already
ready to kick some some butt
and we are playing the uh king art games
guys which is me
elliot and will against the iron lords
of gaming and i have one question for
you guys do you want to play with
regular victory points set on normal or
do we want to set it on higher
or normal makes the match faster of
course but on higher
makes it more brutal i'd say but with
normal eventually we can do two matches
if we are
let's just do two matches yeah okay
let's try
to try to make the the the defeat i'm
about to take
longer all right here we go
there we here we go okay
so shall i start with a little
explanation or maybe like a little a few
tips
for those first coming in all right so
we currently have
three factions here right now polanya
saxony and roosevelt
um if i were to give a little developer
pro tip here
i would say that those who are first
coming into iron harvest and need like a
little bit of
extra uh boost so to speak i would say
that rusev is definitely the faction to
pick they have a fairly
uh how would i say like a fairly high
skill
floor so to speak so they're relatively
easy to play uh with polany on the other
end as kind of more
uh for the more skilled players which is
obviously why i'm picking them
um other than that saxony is super super
uh straightforward um has a lot of
um potential to hold ground very much so
i think that we've got a fairly good
setup here right now
um this is going to be very interesting
i'm very curious to see
which units you've all picked in reserve
and how that's going to
work out for you all right there we go
unfortunately we're all in the same chat
so there's not much we can really
discuss on strategy without
yeah without giving your hand away
exactly i mean i was going to let you
continue to if you wanted to uh
inform my guys what you're trying to do
to give us a
all jokes aside let's get it going man
all right the match
is awesome so all right look at this
look what we have here
yeah i see that i'm fighting directly
against undead
so we are alone on the bottom so it's
sexy versus saxony wow interesting
okay okay okay so everyone go everyone
attacked the bottom
and at the top is
pointy end in the other person
fair enough that will get you very very
far uh
oh here we go we're about to start
stopping but i'll be fighting my
brothers and sisters yes yes true mirror
match
different heroes though we've come to
different era so that's going to be
interesting it's awesome
for those who aren't familiar i see the
iron lord podcast chat in here
again iron harvest real time strategy
game kind of set in the alternate
reality of 1920 plus just after the
end of the great war so you get to
control very cool
diesel mechs you've got a single plan
campaign a co-op campaign and now we're
doing some skirmishes and stuff like
that
and multiplayer so a lot of options for
the fan it's currently
in open beta right now on steam and the
lord's about to get it in
absolutely the open beta is available
for free right now
on steam so if you want to go check it
out you're more than welcome to it will
be available up until the launch
officially on the first of september
awesome awesome
yeah and our discord channel is now live
so if you've got any questions
feel free to jump on in and there'll be
lots of people willing to share iron
harvest footage
absolutely same thing with the lords any
question guys feel free to shoot us a
shot and we'll try to answer
that for you for sure we've been very
very open to feedback so far
so um
yeah we've been working very very hard
this past week
pushed like a whole bunch of patches out
based on uh
feedback and bug reports coming straight
from the community so
uh we've been really hauling ass to make
sure that
uh we've got as much you know in as
uh people want for uh the launch and
beyond that like we will definitely be
open to feedback and a further change
because we do plan to support
iron harvest after launch and beyond
awesome yeah and speaking of which we're
already getting feedback from the chat
he longs for the polonium rifleman buff
because he says it's better
polonia is better three few threes
because the matt wright encouraged more
ranged fighting
yeah so there's definitely um we
recently made a few changes
to uh saxony and particularly rusev
because particularly the the
base infantry for roosevet were maybe a
little bit overtuned
and we also made a few adjustments to
some units for saxony
and we hope that will kind of level out
the balance a little bit on that end but
we will definitely be paying very close
attention
um to both what the players are saying
as well as the esl tourney that is
happening
right now yeah and we are basically
we're collecting data from that
as we speak to try and get an idea of
so that we actually have some statistics
and data that we can work with
um so that we can make some balancing
decisions we're definitely pilani is
definitely one of the factions and
particularly the rifleman
is something we want to look into um
but yeah so that's that's possibly
something for the future
awesome i would say awesome boogie man
is
and king art games will this be coming
to xbox one and series x
their console guys are already that's a
very very very amazing question
and so of course it will however
unfortunately we had to postpone it a
little bit
so early 21 so in the beginning of next
year
um yeah and again again take a look on
our social media
the moment we know we will definitely
let you guys know
awesome awesome so casper guys you still
have hope it is coming
so right absolutely the strategy is
going down
right now guys are focused attic is very
quiet when he's quiet he is focused that
means he's really taking this serious
undead and pity how we feeling so far we
strategizing guys
yes
yeah right now in the first in the first
early moments of the game it's really
important to try
and grab resources uh whether that is
from
resource points here so things like iron
mines and oil pumps
uh or certain stockpiles scattered
around the map
anything that can get you an early
in-game advantage
um there is uh from what i understand
there is a bit of feedback regarding
uh the crates because of course this is
kind of something that's a little bit
unique to iron harvest
um so it is definitely something that is
fairly new to a lot of players and we've
gotten a lot of feedback about it which
has been fantastic
and uh yeah i look forward to seeing how
we're going to be
working with that and how we're going to
be balancing that in the future um
yeah it's really really exciting it's
great to see how many people have been
giving us so much feedback and have
taken such an interest
in this particular game awesome yeah
speaking of which uh
i don't want to inundate it does but the
questions are flying in from the lord
chat
they ain't loving this so if if you
can't answer any more questions we we
have a few more coming in
absolutely sure all right but i can okay
so uh
i guess maybe this might be for toby
that's the first one which is red alert
three he says
how about playstation five console guys
asking
and um uh down says any chance we will
get a ping
system for in-game communication yeah
that's what i was going to ask yeah
because i just got
attacked and i had no way to tell anyone
that i was needed help
for the playstation thing let us like
first steps first
we will do it on ps4 and xbox one and
then we'll see but
so far we are really focusing on the on
the
on the classic um or the the current gem
and
the pink system is definitely something
that elliot was talking about like
collecting feedback and stuff so that's
definitely something that
uh yeah uh a ping system is definitely
planned
nice nice nice yeah okay cause they
definitely want to know that
and then um wow these questions are i
don't know if you could answer all these
but we'll see
um he said uh shout out to hr obama he
said uh obviously
uh will mouse and keyboard support be
optional for the console and the second
question
will be um will it support the razer
turret
or keyboard and mouse oh yeah on xbox
okay i can probably answer this question
so um right now we're still undecided
regarding that um because obviously
especially for a real-time strategy game
having mouse and keyboard on console
kind of gives you a bit of an advantage
i would say like just from a pure
hardware
uh side regarding that so this is
definitely a decision that we are
making very very carefully um so
currently right now it's tba
but we are looking into having that
potential support in the future
awesome awesome sounds good sounds good
and uh actually we're gonna see what's
going on with from will's standpoint
in reference to um maybe the lore and
you know just think from mirai's people
i know toby we've talked about this
uh previously at uh at pax when when
things were normal before the pandemic
you know but one thing that really
strikes people is this whole diesel punk
aesthetic right
it's so cool you got these big macs you
know this now just break down to the
people this is kind of based on a
real lore right i mean someone already
created a
universe right and this the game is kind
of based on that
that is correct so the the game is
called iron harvest 1920 plus
that's also the name of the universe so
there was this polish
artist called jacob buczelski and he
actually created this kind of universe
and for him it was was a combination
between
classical rural landscapes and these
giant mix
so he imagined this world where people
kind of well lived through world war one
as as you'd expect but instead of tanks
they had these giant
mechs who were great which were created
to
help the people in pharmacy and so on
but
you know as it as it is every time
instead they were misused for
um war and in this universe if
maybe you saw that in 2014 or so it it
became
uh somewhat um like known on the
internet so it was shared a lot on
on uh yeah twitter and so on and
um and he was back then approached by
board game guys who created a board game
out of that and maybe the guys who
enjoy board games might know scythe so
that's the
shares the same universe but it's not
the same lore of course so the lore is
somewhat different
while or the lore is somewhat the same
however
scythe takes care a lot or or deals with
the with the economic side of
this post-world war one scenario and
um iron harvest really takes care about
the conflict and
deals with that so it's war forecast and
not
economy focused gotcha gosh it looks
real cool shout out to fc violet in the
chat
she said someone says rts this is my
type of game there you go everybody's
excited that's cool
all right uh vipassien um always says
will
observation mode i guess be in there in
this game
spectator mode is probably what he means
and that's definitely something
that we are working on as we speak so as
the esl tournament is currently going on
that's definitely something that has to
be there and we want to have there
no doubt no doubt shout out to addict
this question is for you our lord
sinister's in the chat he said addict if
you lose your lord status is gone
so he just giving you a little extra
pressure he's more welcome to come in
here
just add a little fuel to the fire
welcome to man
none of that nonsense come from here
shout out to archimedes uh i know the
game hasn't even officially launched yet
but can we expect to see some of the
other factions that are quoted at the
beginning
of the polanya campaign so i can
probably say that for now
spoiler yeah you may see that we may see
some further factions uh depending on
how well the game does of course
um there is already um
some we've already been toying around
with like the potential of
having more factions in the future uh
but nothing that i can confirm
officially just yet
that's still cool information getting
excited you're getting
even more excited with the potential
really cool really cool so it's always
important to
like first things first right make sure
absolutely
steps and then correct how it takes you
yeah definitely we don't want to put the
cart before the horse here like we
um we definitely no we don't want to
just support
uh the game with just you know things
like dlc and stuff like we really want
to
uh do more than that we wanted to keep
like updates and new features coming in
the future
um observer or spectator mode is
definitely one of those things it's
a feature that's been really heavily
requested by a lot of players along with
things like a potential map editor
is something that i heard that people
are really into um
so these are these are things they will
probably not being at launch because
these are kind of things to come in for
later because obviously game comes first
yes um but afterwards yeah these are
definitely things
we would love to look at and see how we
can give
our players more tools um to really
share the love of real-time strategy
awesome
awesome it's really good good stuff
really excited people
are really loving it the aesthetic and
everything else that's going on
so i want to say i'm sorry yeah go ahead
i know i was just actually going to ask
has any of you already built a mech yet
yes oh excellent all right yeah cause
i'm seeing here like quite a lot of
infantry and i thought you know what
maybe i should build a few
anti-infantry mix and see if we can take
care of that problem real quick mix
things up a little bit
um but go ahead what was your question
no no just
in general elliot you cannot tell them
what your plans are yes yes that's not
how
it's totally fine like it doesn't matter
because no matter if i tell you or not
i'm still going to beat you oh
see that's confidence toby that's
confidence
did you guys did you guys see the
netflix series dark
did anyone watch that so things are
going to repeat themselves over and over
again
how's that how's that going for you fam
no comments oh that's right
talking spicy he's feeling good right
now shout out to will he'll scream
oh well played in one place
nick is focused on dead focus man how we
feeling her dead
my infantry rush failed
i think we're doing pretty good so far
actually from what i can tell
points like you guys pushed me off the
control point right from the start when
i was almost got in the beginning
indeed indeed wilhelm's q with the jet
he's like you better win
attic he's giving you some support
better win yeah that's the support we
get out here lives are on the line
eagles are on the line this is awesome
this has nothing to do with my ego all
right
now what ghosts did to me that was on my
ego
this this was this is nothing i don't
intend on winning this i i did intend on
winning the halo wars 2 matchless that's
all good it's all good
nice oh they're coming for their stuff
oh no hey that's mine
oh spicy get up back it up back it up
i love somebody submitted yeah
so talk to us a little bit will just
give us some perspective you know
obviously you're the manager manager and
everything as far as the game and
you know just how you feeling about it
i am totally hyped i mean it's so good
to see this come
to life uh so we've been with the
backers uh who
kick-started this project and pretty
much we owe so much to them because they
trusted us and um they've been with us
yeah and discord
uh for about two years now i knew that i
was gonna have
it and yeah it's
been to see everybody flooding in and
all these backers who've
stayed with us and um given the feedback
and you know
seeing the improvements and the patches
come in and like the to and fro
it's really exhilarating you know and
speaking of feedback
some just came in
and it looked like we went down kind of
kind of quickly there sir
victory
because i was just like sitting back
waiting to get my necks out
wow
wow i was exactly asking these things do
you want to play with victory points you
said yeah let's do that
i have no problem with it okay so how
are we doing we keep it keeping things
as
is are we are we mixing things up what
are we doing for a second
let's go for the total kill yeah total
annihilation okay
all right okay so we need to do this
we need to do the code thingy again yeah
sure i don't know
that uh i'll get that up a little bit
just saying
should we increase the resources as well
just to get that
want the next so i invited someone yeah
elliot nice so
invite i mean will as well
i will have the lord of gaming
oops here friend
barry okay so once will accepts the
invite i can create
no
invite friend and
there you go and then
pdp just accept and then
pdp do it perfect invite friend
create invite code copy paste
there you go that's code one all right
i'm gonna send that to the lord so we
can get in there
can i ask a question while we're while
we're doing this absolutely
so each of the um each of the factions
we play they all have their own
specialty quote-unquote commanders if
you will do they all have very similar
to the point where they're pretty much
the same or do like one
have one factions
uh have like more of a you know
an advantage over another sure so
um essentially each of the heroes that
each faction has
um basically represent a particular
facet of the playstyle of
that particular fashion or faction so
for instance for pilania you have
anna and uh lechos um
so both of them kind of represent the
kind of the play style of planning which
is
fast mobile kind of guerilla warfare
um and that's what we kind of wanted to
have each hero represent a
like a facet of uh anna of course is a
long-range sniper
um who is fairly quick on her feet
whereas uh lekh is
kind of a bit more of a diminutive
maggie's got like
uh this like really heavy hammer uh
which he uses in melee
and he is very much a representation i
think
of the kind of uh national pride
uh that that particular faction has and
you can very clear that here in his
character and if you also played a
little bit of
the uh first five campaign missions
which are also available in the open
beta go do it it's awesome you should go
play it yes
um then you will also see how that comes
forward there as well and that's kind of
the idea that we had
for each hero from within the fashion so
they all have their own
unique abilities um that kind of
dovetail
with that particular faction that
they're wearing
yeah we just sent it check the launch
room we checked it get check it at it
we sent the code i said the second one
uh it wouldn't let me join it let me try
it again
okay it should be two so actually a
question for you
um is there are specific factions better
geared for different strategies
i know that's very common in like rts
games is like
one one one faction's better for rushing
this one's
better for defensive plays that's
something that comes into play with you
guys or is it more based on
the player's skill level to how that
faction reacts
yes um no it's basically a bit of a move
it's a little bit of column a it's a
little bit of column b um as i was
talking a little bit beforehand at the
start of our first match is that yes
um some of the factions are maybe a
little bit easier to play
depending on your skill level um but
they are also definitely
tuned towards particular play styles
like i was just saying about
polanya being a bit more guerilla
warfare style like uh saxony for
instance is really good on the defensive
and for like
taking and holding particular parts of
terrain and roosevelt
is well i mean i can't say it much
better than rush b
yeah yeah uh
one one question guys do you want to
remain on the same position so that
undead is on the same level with me or
do you want to go
you free you can mix up maybe the iron
law team
you you're mixing up the positions by
clicking on the on the
arrows on the left side you can youtube
you can have toby
give me somebody fresh okay
i need fresh meat you need fresh meat i
don't
want uh am i matched with elliott um oh
yeah we are okay
that's okay i mean are you guys ready so
i put it on very long victory points so
they are not disabled completely but
just double the time
everything else is ready to go all right
all right
ready to rumble are we gonna pick the
same factions or do we want to do
different ones
yeah i'll go with the same patch okay
okay let's do same factions then
um
and shout out to stitch 6669 he said
maybe i missed this but he said is the
game going to mouse keyboard on console
uh so do you want to do you want to take
this
or shall i okay sure
okay sure uh so right now that
is undecided as we are
still um of course uh the console
version has been delayed a little bit
uh because covet 19 has done a number on
everybody i think i think we can all
agree on that i agree
um and we
are undetermined about that because uh
bringing mouse and keyboard to console
for a real-time strategy game
does represent a certain
advantage for premieres if they just
have the specific hardware for it
right uh that's something worth thinking
about it
but we want to make that decision very
very carefully so for right now
tba uh and stay tuned
question if you do decide to go with
mouse and keyboard support on xbox
would you potentially have maybe a
cross-play scenario going on
if you do decide that because i feel
like if you don't do one you're not
going to do the other but if you do one
you might do the other
me personally i want the pc people over
there little pc land i don't know
what they're doing
uh if i play on xbox i want to play
only other people that don't have a
keyboard and mouse
but that's how i want that type no i
agree
there's definitely an advantage for
keyboard and all yeah so
as a developer i personally find that of
course i want as many people to play
with as many people
as possible but as you do say there is
definitely that kind of unfair
advantage you would get right um with
having keyboard and mouse support on
console
and we do have cross-play planned
for across all three platforms that
we're doing so that would be steam
the epic store and gog okay um
but between pc and console uh there is
it's both from a design perspective and
from a technical perspective
we're not i don't think that's very
likely right now
fair enough fair enough totally
understand like i said it adds that
extra layer
you know so you know sometimes you don't
want to split the player base for those
who don't have it
for keyboard and mouse versus those who
do and definitely want to keep things
fair from a playing field standpoint and
a balance standpoint
exactly you can understand that
completely
i always wondered how many people are
really playing with mouse and keyboard
on consoles i never
never met someone who actually does that
uh i do that but um anyways
congratulations you've met you should
have swapped phone numbers
there you go my first time
mm-hmm yeah i see what you're saying fc
violet
yeah i mean as far as uh matching
players va input and stuff like that but
for right now it looks like you know the
devs that's not in division right now
you know maybe in the future that def
definitely does change
but yeah there's always that advantage
thing what's going on midway monster
what's going on smitty smith
we're live this is match two going on
the iron challenge versus the devs of
iron
harvest and the iron laws themselves so
having some fun setting up
maybe a little bit more competitive
round two guys
yeah and i'll just keep quicker now oh
i'm welcome to take my spot there called
neato no no no you don't
spicy it's spicy i i respect the vets of
the giant
you you know that if you're gonna be
spicy i have to shoot back
all right i can't i can't just take that
like now it's all good man
so tell me you know as we you have along
our travels you know
and seeing you guys in development man
it's really cool to see
you know how far this has come since the
last time we saw you i believe it was uh
pax 2020
i believe what was that february i'm
gonna say february march
february march yeah yeah it was a great
year
it feels so long right right i'm saying
the same but on the other hand me
traveling the world like on a daily
basis i actually
it feels good to be at home for a while
right so that's
that's definitely something a new
feeling for me
because by that time we would have met
it which is not a bad thing of course we
would have met on e3 already and so on
but yeah
you know for for me we're traveling as i
said as a daily basis thing
it's it's nice to be at home for a while
okay question for the dev team again fc
violent
was to know um how far are we from
coming
out officially i know we're in beta but
uh they
they're thirsty they're they're
anticipating man they want that that
iron harvest man
so the you know the joke unfortunately
only works in
in europe but the game is called 19 iron
harvest 1920 plus which is one
920 which is first of sep september 20.
everywhere else then except the usa
there it's
nine one twenty but the first of
september is the release day and
as i said the joke works only in europe
it's still close man it's too close yeah
it's very close it's in four weeks or so
right yesterday it's yeah
you know it does feel polished so you
know it i could
totally see how this game is coming out
soon
and that dude over here trying to take
my iron mine and i'm not about that life
so come over here
nice little map features which uh can
really turn the tide of battle
yeah talk about that uh like i said
they're different the terrains and
and those map features how influential
is that
well i mean you have to learn the map
don't you you gotta not only know your
enemy you gotta know the terrain
and yeah skilled commander will um
figure it out get the experience and we
reward that in this game you know you've
got to know the optimal pieces of cover
and
you know cover is everything it gives
you the advantage when you're 1v1
like this um these two raspberries here
uh
and yeah they were hidden behind a wall
and fortunately i had grenades which
blew up
all and now that gives me the advantage
cover can only help you so far but the
buildings are garrisonable which
you know if you can find the right uh
building with the right um
coverage over a certain like uh area
that's important to you like overlooking
a flag or a resource point you can
you know hold it so you don't have to
spend a load of resources on bunkers you
know
um so there's a lot of like hidden depth
there to repeat play
[Music]
absolutely let me ask an undead a
question from the lords you know now
that you've been playing for a while
you're getting your feeling what are
some of the
and you've actually wrote some very cool
articles on lords of gaming.net in
reference to iron harvest so now that
you're getting this uh
combat live action give us give us your
feel of it now in this skirmish
multiplayer 353 kind of mode
well one thing i really liked about the
game like they mentioned the cover
system i love
love the cover system because i feel
like with a lot of rts games it's
whoever can
build the troops the fastest and then
bum rush the other person before they're
ready but with this you really get the
vibe of
you can win a battle even if you're very
heavily outnumbered
if you have the select terrain and you
know
i like that unit i like the unit
okay continue
[Music]
the time frame is so unique and like
there's so many rts games that feel like
they're just
like i've played a ton of rts games and
they all feel kind of similar
this one when i hopped into it i went
okay this is this has a curve to it
that's way different and that was really
what made it a lot of fun was
the fact that it was so different from
every rts on the market and it really
made you push and change how you play
these kind of games
gotcha gotcha yeah yeah definitely oh
we're really slogging
out of the middle here isn't it who's
the first one who's going to bring up a
neck
because these infantry are looking
mighty squishy
oh it's getting hot it's getting hot in
here let's go
let's get that diesel
great fight over there what's going on
[Laughter]
okay okay question 6669
he says one question he says he knows
the current focus is current gen
but he says what kind of update could we
expect from the
upcoming gen maybe from a first person
from fps textures from
frames per second or updated textures
things of that nature
well let me answer like that don't
accept expect an update that's nothing
we can promise that's nothing we're
working on right now so
if there's something then we will let
you know but
as of right now there is really nothing
to talk about unfortunately
fair enough still early in the
development cycle
later in the development excuse me
sure the the centuries do they actually
produce more cover
than the actual building themselves or
is it just one or the other
well you can upgrade them that's the
thing with the sentries you can upgrade
them to have machine guns and anti-mech
cannons
versus a building yeah i think they are
a bit more stable
mechs can't walk through them mechs can
walk through buildings
so if you've got troops stationed in the
building it's only there as long as the
mech doesn't you know
can't come charging through um maybe you
know more about that
[Music]
yeah so essentially um bunkers like this
century there
that was there previously i should say
um
yeah they generally provide much better
cover uh
to infantry inside them um
that's definitely for sure and you can
equip them and upgrade them with
different weaponry
uh the weaponry is all unique to their
individual factions
um so for instance for russviews the
sentry are definitely the
more tougher uh bunker so to speak
um and they're wet the weapons that they
upgrade with are a bit more powerful
uh but they try that off with a bit more
limited functionality when it comes
to infantry being inside them
cool cool let me ask questions to the
dirty myself um just like as we're
getting close
you know to release and you're winding
down i know the grind must be intense
for getting everything worked out like
what are some of the lessons you guys
have learned with iron harvest doing
this whole development process
um so probably one of the things that
uh we really have been coming to terms
with is
um this was definitely a game that
became much bigger than we anticipated
like
when we first started out uh we first
had in mind
uh that we already knew we wanted to
make a real-time strategy game
um at the time and what we did is we
basically checked in with various
communities around um the particular
genre
and we asked them hey so what do you
want we basically we had a survey that
we sent out
um asking them basically hey so if you
want to see
something from a real-time strategy game
what in particular like what kind of
features do you want to see like what
kind of focus do you want
and one of the things that came about
out of it was we want a very strong
single-player campaign experience
um and of course at the time as i think
toby was saying
uh we of course had uh jacob's work
uh going viral at the time and that was
definitely something that we saw and
we're like
yeah this is a world that we can see so
many different stories
in uh at this point and
um yeah there's a lot we could do that
so we went and we talked to jacob and we
said like hey we would really love to
make a game
about your world and he he was
completely on board he's uh we used to
work with him like he still
uh we still talk with him about like the
particular details of the world and
things like that
um so and it's been really really great
i think especially to see
how excited he has been um for iron
harvest
um but yeah that was definitely one of
the things that we wanted to focus on
was like starting with single player we
did a kickstarter
uh campaign we said okay like we want to
start out with you know a reasonable
amount of money and we will see where
this goes
and we were completely blown away by
the um but basically by the response
from everybody we
more than easily managed to hit all our
kickstarter goals
uh within time and yeah we were
absolutely thrilled and that's kind of
one of the things that we've been seeing
like how many things that people are
like yeah
there's been a real hunger for a
real-time strategy
like in this vein for a while now so
it's been very tricky to find like how
can we
live up to those expectations in a way
that you know makes as many people as
happy as
we can make them be um but i think we
find
we found a good balance between what we
want to do what we set out to do
and uh what we can do to
uh make sure that iron harvest is the
real-time strategy game that everybody
or that as many people want as they as
they can be i mean
also screw up with the you know the
memories of such classics you know
like home world command and conquer age
of empires
and then it was so refreshing to be a
community which also has that you know
i mean i know nostalgia is a powerful
thing but there's like a genuine
fondness for like yeah a good uh you
know good single-player
narrative you know it's not all just
multiplayer although multiplayer is cool
don't get me wrong
but you know so it's yeah i don't like
what you're trying to do over here man
you got to get off my hill
so let's talk about these knights that
are coming out now everyone's keep
coming after me what is up with this
guy with a uh that's just an easy target
i zoom
you want to see something cool yes
take to the skies my people need me
quick there we go two more questions
rolling there there's like is it going
to be clan structure so clans can battle
each other
and then um the other question is are
any plans for
um or or are there already aerial and
naval units
okay so there are no aerial or naval
units
for now but that is all i can say about
it um
perhaps maybe stay tuned in the future
stay tuned and anything with the claims
uh so for that we've had a lot of
different ideas of what we could do
uh additionally with multiplayer um
because of course like again
single player and campaign was really
our primary focus when we first started
out and we just saw immediately how many
people
wanted various uh stuff for multiplayer
of course
um and that's definitely something we
are staying open for feedback
uh both on and after launch um so by all
means
uh i would say drop into the iron
harvest discord and drop it into
justin's channel and we will be more
than happy to take a look to see what we
can do i mean
we're super pumped as a team and i think
our ambition has already proven to be
pretty high with what we're trying to do
here and it all depends on our success i
guess post release you know what we're
able to do
um but yeah there's such a rich world uh
with uh 1920 and jakob
and he wants to yeah do more we want to
do more and let's see what other
factions we can get in there
that's awesome guys
have you seen these mechs that uh we
destroyed well it's called iron harvest
and thank you for those extra resources
because my infantry units
can go and self give me a night little
resource
well they were your resources oh they
are mine targets
here all your bases shall belong to me
wow the conquering is going down
i feel bad
[Music]
learning experiences learning
experiences
this is like iron giant but reversed um
yeah that's true
toby uh racer gundam is asking what he
wants to know the name of the artist
that the game's world is based on again
he's called jakub rusalski and you
spell him r-o-z rosalski
and there you can find him yeah back out
of his art station pages
it's full of amazing stuff yeah very
cool also i want to shout you guys out
because i
told me as well the the music if you
guys are listening right now in the
background that is the iron harvest
soundtrack
i felt it was amazing like really cool
music a lot of different tones even for
the factions and stuff like that
do we knows behind that and just that
whole that whole process
um okay so who wants to take this
question
if anyone does anyone know we need you
but you can ah okay so uh from what i
understand
is that a lot of the music is done uh by
our friend adam skarupa um who
i believe contributed a lot of the music
you may have
know him i think he worked don't quote
me on this i think he worked on some of
the previous
witcher uh games yes
um yeah because of course if we're going
to have
you know an art style a world based on
the art style of a polish
artist of course we're going to have
music from
a published composer of course nice
it's a really international project it's
really nice to see uh so many people
from different parts of europe working
together on this
i mean i have to say what attracted me
to the project was exactly that
you know working with uh you know like
polish and
you know russian and uh various
influences which you don't always see
in computer gaming you know correct that
that's what i feel yeah the unique
nature of iron harvest you have that
it's
yeah look at this ridiculous mech that's
the size of like three
walking through not even the biggest one
that's not even the wow
that's huge man look at these look at
these little
man
[Music]
beside me uh i was
um i'm currently having a dealing with
um
i feel like you ain't doing your job but
they coming up my flake like this
i was hoping you guys read chad when i
was talking before
i know pete what what are you doing
oh
i don't know how i feel about this oh i
see oh i see the
oh now i see why you're not moving at
all okay
meanwhile i have the biggest mech build
so if you want
if you want to switch switch to my
oh [ __ ] i brought oh god what you want
to do
i'm getting out of here let's
[Music]
oh yeah you're gonna get it now son
you're gonna get it
[Laughter]
yeah we should definitely get that one
out we we wear our influences
quite lightly yes yes that is very uh
we love it we absolutely love it shout
out they jumped
out there yeah i agree oh my goodness
the music does fit oh god there's
another one coming over here
this is mexico like i'm pl i'm playing
leads of extraordinary gentlemen man
[Music]
how we looking petey how he's how we
feeling we ain't looking good
right now that's if someone can come
push this mac in so i can rebuild my
headquarters but look have you seen
my stuff over here the only thing i'm
pushing is my way out of this game
can't run there's no running down there
okay i will say one thing i don't know
what this advanced workshop's working on
but about oh yeah there we go shout out
to luke lodi and said he goes he said
are you are you guys a dev teams fan of
halo wars
he said getting an rts on console must
mean they've seen the goods and bads of
other efforts
absolutely so uh halo wars is definitely
i think
one of the prime examples of a real-time
strategy
on um on console of course
so that's definitely a title that we
will certainly be looking at
um i mean of course like creative
assembly of course are masters of the
craft so
obviously um if you're if you're gonna
learn learn from the best of course
and see what they do and see what what
they what they learned
everyone should actually go talk to them
with them at some point that would be
really nice
that's awesome gentlemen i feel like
there's one very important feature of
the game you
are not familiar with it's the button r
now don't laugh it's a retreat button
however when you retreat
when you're retreating that's important
right there you need to learn about the
retweet button okay no no no
where am i retreating to toby i'm at my
base where am i retreating
push the button real quick and you'll
see for yourself
take the destroyed the back who's being
horrible you went too late
so the retreat button if you if you push
r uh
then your unit will run back to your
headquarters or to
either to the headquarters or workshop
or whatever if you push r again
you will immediately repair it like an
insta heal i did i already did i already
used it once
oh okay well then there's a cool down of
course
i was waiting for the cool down because
homeboy had a gatling gun up there
shooting me i had to shoot that for like
five minutes
and then when i got rid of that oopsie
oh great there's another one there's
another
one here that's coming in so i don't
know what we're supposed to be building
now
no hold up hold up i ain't giving this
dude the satisfaction
come on
man the only person killing like me is
me
wow there we go that's how we going out
that's how we go now
that's exactly how we're going out oh
where's the honor
at least i can control that and what is
this
gundam looking ship right here you see
this i have three genomes mechs in my
base just wrecking everything
what is that
this this thing looks like something i'd
run from man
[Music]
this looks like one of the things to
make a a zoid man like i don't excuse
you put the cursor over that what just
get that big
wow the sm hm70
and there you have it
[Laughter]
these magazines ridiculous gg please
stop that
it was just it was
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh has been
absolutely fun man like i said talk to
people in reference to like i said
for those who don't know again how far
out we are
you know said from release and also that
single player campaign that's also
exciting
too because i love that you guys are
taking care of attention to detail in
reference to
an actual solo campaign absolutely so we
actually have
21 campaign missions featuring all three
factions
um as well as an hour's worth of
cinematics of course
so um but you know don't let me talk
about it
you can download the beta you can play
the first five missions of the polandia
campaign
um and you can check that all that good
stuff out for yourself
and see if you like it or not and if you
uh play now you get all these pre-season
rewards
i was gonna ask you just saw that
season's button do you guys plan on like
releasing seasons every couple of months
or how do you guys plan on doing that
and what type of rewards do you guys
plan on so
i'm not gonna go super super into detail
right now but essentially the idea
is that you can essentially you can gain
or unlock
cosmetics um for your profile and
later in the future perhaps skins for
your mix um
then you basically you can unlock them
by playing the game
by um completing certain challenges
um you can actually take a look at it if
you want to right now uh i can't tell
you exactly for each how many
days each season is going to be um
but essentially what i can tell you is
that
this preseason is basically like kind of
a test run to see like hey
iron out some bugs uh see if
everything's working
and um we are going to try and do this
if we can do it technically
we would like to see if those who have
completed the preseason or are working
on the preseason that
they get to keep those rewards upon
launch if they
you know buy the game awesome that is
awesome
yeah tell me i'm sorry yeah so the
important questions do you want to have
a third match or
do you feel like you can't bear it
anymore and
yeah have a third match but i i want
i want one of you people's on our team
yeah we got to fix it we gotta mix it up
it'll be the fight or what we're mixing
ain't none of this dev teaming up thing
anymore man
okay killing the other dev it's not
happening like
let's split the teams okay guys come on
let's do that
how will we do that do you will you i
want that
will you decide i'm sorry yeah who who
uh
who who wants to jump over who wants to
jump over no no he didn't know who i
want the best person on our team
so the best is by far elliot elliott
come on over man
we welcome you now who's going over to
the damn team from the lords
right obviously that's going to be pd
why it's got to be
throw me on the other side you know what
i'll go over there i'll go
i'll go i'll go over with them and
you're going to i already said it i'll
go
it's too late it's too late
so i should probably forewarn here that
uh
of course as on the dev team we also
have held our own tournaments when we
were first testing out multiplayer
and i should warn you here that
statistically speaking i
am the worst player on the dev team um
now i hope that won't be too big of a
deal
here but let's just cross our fingers
and find out all right
well iron lords i put the new code for
the custom match in there please uh
wrap that up yep one of one of you guys
need to take it and i will then create
another one
uh you're the worst idiot from the team
how how's that mystically speaking yeah
i don't wanna hear about what it means
statistically it's either
it's either you win or lose it just
means that we have we have even better
players on
in our company here right now that's all
that's all it means
all i know ellie is you hear they ain't
that's very true that is very true and
of course he tells you this after he's
jumped
yes absolutely of course i mean i do all
the big talk and [ __ ] but you know
you got the numbers speak otherwise
early in in the early days of iron
harvest i've been at some
multiplayer event thing and it was like
a like a
like a huge um how do you call that lan
party a huge lamp planter thing
and i won 21 versus one so i i won 21
matches and lost just one match and that
was the very first match where i
tried to see how things work and then i
won every match because back in the day
you could easily do a smiley rush smelly
other
small small um polania max with the with
the rifle
in their hand like this two two leg
thing and
with them you could easily rush to the
other base which by the time i was also
playing against
max one of the other developers and some
some programmer and so on who were
supposed to be like the bestest
from uh king art games and yeah
my similarity rush
i might have and i might not have looked
up on youtube
cheat tactics oh my god
somebody just accept the second code
please look man look man
i i was looking to win all right and i
knew the only way i could
even remotely close that gap is with the
cheapest texture that's what the online
community is
ridiculous i put the second code into
chat guys we'll have to switch it over
yeah everyone is in there just game
addict attic needs to
needs to push the ready button
alex starts your stream also so yeah
which team which faction do you want to
play
you choose and then uh will and i will
take what's what's left
so you're going with raspberry then pd
okay and then what's the game plan here
will what do you want poland or section
uh i'll go with uh sucks me
okay for me then
[Music]
shout out to racy gonna make addict take
a tattoo bet on the next match okay nope
[Laughter]
out your mind with that nonstance get
out of here if i had the chat
if i had to chat up i'd probably block
you shout out to jessica
she says just got knocked out of the esl
tournament what's going on here
oh no jessica it's i it's it's kissland
i think
it's her name on on youtube or twitch
and so on
she's doing really good i think she she
won three matches or so
no so sad to hear that you were kicked
out
on day one
the thing with the esl tournament is
you've got four qualifiers so if you
lose you can always enter another
qualifier
gotcha exactly if you guys can educate
our audience on the tournament like
what's going on
yeah so we have a cooperation with esl
which the esports uh
how do you want to call them
confederation or whatever the guys who
are doing all the esports
events and stuff and we have a
cooperation with them that they
uh from today have an esport tournament
running iron harvest
we have over 150 people who signed up i
think when i checked the last time
110 actually really checked in so quite
a big number
of people and there from today we have
the
qualifiers going and the cool thing is
that on the end of the month
there's digital gamescom and on
digitalgamescom we will have the
finale of this iron harvest tournament
and i will be there
uh and will be casting that as a
co-moderator with these
that's awesome so i'm going i'm going to
digital gamescom
which confused a lot of people very cool
very cool shout out to the basement
radio arcade practical subject if addict
doesn't win he should shave his beard
and shout out to fc what if what that's
the tack addict thing
shout out to fc violet there's plenty of
other people we can slander on here that
has
attic not in the name it's more fun to
slaughter you
oh shout out to fc violet he says to the
iron lords
what does this game remind you of
so this is strictly there's actually a
game there's a game
there's a game i reviewed recently
called ancestors legacy
like obviously it's not the same thing i
actually would like this game more
because of these mechs like these scary
mechs that
just that just roll up and i just have
this oh yeah i'm done
look because the mex is i think the max
is what makes this game unique
is the fact that some of these mechs
look
crazy it's like that what i showed you
looked like a gundam
like it looked beast i go like i love
the designs
undead what about you like what does
this game remind you
what are the feels honestly
like playing through this game even
though like i'm
distinctly struggling um right now um
is like i haven't felt this excited
about like an rts game since like
i got like age of empires two in a
cereal box as a kid
and then like that played that for like
300 hours as a kid
so like i'm gonna put some serious time
into this game and maybe not get
steamrolled every five seconds
petey what about you what does it feel
like
i mean it makes me feel like the olden
days when you like you just picked up
like an fps for the first i'm not good
i'm sorry
an rtf very first time so it feels good
and different
i like it all i know is dez you know i'm
gonna have to ask you to pull up after
this game comes out right like
yeah i can't i can't just have one
incident
define my whole life in this thing like
i gotta have more time man i gotta have
more time oh my gosh out to the chest
squirrelly down until i see the chat is
this going upgrade
xbox series currently right now it's
going to be current gen only
no plans right now you know but who's to
know what happens in the future but
right now current gen
boogie man 5 super chat if attic doesn't
win he should get a tattoo of the iron
harvest logo
oh see man look at these people with
this nonsense going on here man
it doesn't sound like crazy there's a
guy on instagram who is tattooing
himself with jakub's art
and it's amazing to see it's really
crazy yeah well
that's awesome there's even there's even
people with kingdom come deliverance
tattoos so
there's there's some there are some
great great people out there i played
like
15 hours of that game man i i don't
think there's ever been a game that
frustrates me more man that game is hard
like oh yeah that's real life that's
real life system it's it's like
it's like hardcore skyrim and like that
like hard hard hardcore especially
playing the difficulty votes and again
that's something we've always we
followed there's a flag right here
let's talk about the action let's get
into it
all right all right so little pro tip
from me to you
guys is uh you all have these resource
points here right
so you can upgrade those to get more
resources
in the long haul uh all you gotta do is
you gotta select it and at the bottom
right there's a button for it or you can
just press f so that might help you all
out here so we actually get enough of
those resources to build more of those
mechs
wow no no no no no say that again say
that again
because what's important is that you're
sharing you're sharing resources so if
one of your team gets a resource point
everyone benefits from that
exactly so that's basically with team
play in general is that
um if i'm earning more resources
everybody's earning more resources
at least on the team side gotcha when
what exactly because i more resources
i'm about that life but i need to
i need to know what you said again
sure so go ahead and select any one
of the resource points that you own
right now and then press
f to earn bread oh
see this is how you guys are getting
those tanks and stuff on me man
i didn't wonder man i was like there
ain't no way they got the resources for
this stuff
oh there you have it yeah easy stretch
the attitude we are cheating that's
that's okay
i'm low-key changing that man you guys
are cheating
now you understand the magic this is
awesome yeah the other pro tip
is with the sentry um bunkers and things
you can rotate them if you just hold
down the right
mouse button and you can then take it
that makes sense okay
you've got one looking in the wrong
direction here
yeah don't get me wrong
did that pro tip help on there oh
that changed the whole game
what do you think also dev team some of
the common
uh mistakes players make sometimes in
these type of matches
one of the mistakes that's that's one of
them i do a lot is for example
neglecting the uh victory points i
constantly forget about them
and victory points i mean the the flags
you need to take care of them
if you're playing an online match and
have them turned on don't neglect them
because
once the opponent is able to get some
fortification or something running
then you it's it's hard to win them back
so i will say the biggest criticism i
will have of this game that you guys
have already said that you're
working on is like i feel like the uh
the beacon to show on the map uh
is and i would say that on the mini map
if it's possible to show what everyone
else is at on the map too
like your allies like uh for instance
like it shows where i'm looking at the
map like i would like if it shows me
where they're looking at the map too
like my allies oh you mean like the
uh do me like on the mini map like what
yeah the mini map where it shows like
the little icon that
that shows on the map yeah like
because i'm a huge fan of halo wars and
i really like the aspect that
if i look down there and someone says oh
man something's happening i could just
look at that mini map see exactly where
they're
looking at the map and i could scroll my
icon
right right i see okay yeah sure like
that's definitely like
i think you mean like a pinging system
or something that you can say like hey
look pay attention to this attack this
defend that
why both
if you want someone to see something
specifically and let's say like a
because a lot of people online
on halo wars 2 they don't even use that
ping system so like if something goes
down and i hear something it's nice to
be able to look at the bottom left
and see the icons of where they're
looking at on the map as well
on my there's that that white little
arrow that shows where i am
like i like when i can see theirs too i
get
i get ah yeah that's a fair point maybe
we should uh maybe we should look into
that
like i don't think that's kind of a
thing that we can do you know
it's only about like three weeks until
launch of course well no no i i i wasn't
saying like yeah
i have to sound now should have done it
yesterday
what's funny is that halo wars 1 that
was in there and then halo wars 2 it
wasn't in there at large like it took
them like
six months to put that in there because
they got so much bad
criticism because it wasn't in there
because it was in the original one
i see yeah like it's definitely like i
said yeah we'll definitely be supporting
iron harvest
after launch too so we're open to
suggestions and criticism from
uh from the community and from our
players and
like yeah we we definitely intend to add
and improve upon this game
after launch as well so first of
september since the beginning baby
they do my my dude over here dirty on
undead man
what's going on i'm dead i i
i have mex he got his max he's got a big
boy
looking like it's fine man i'm just
keeping it real with you
nice try to get these mechs over there
like
pronto oh
shucks all right yeah we're gonna go
um
get out of here get out of town rotating
the uh the pill boxes
for that stuff you said you have just
hit r
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah uh hit
r and then when you're back in the base
hit r again oh
we are not doing them shoot them don't
let them run
not doing that no you come back here man
we don't need that nonsense
don't run
oh what is that that's a hero let's get
that hero let's go
nice now shoot that hero shoot anna and
the dead
and the dead uh and you're welcome
undead
i like this mech man i like that oh
there's a man coming at me
i should probably turn around shout out
to
red alert kaiser and gulai gurad
all right those are our um those are the
the big three mechs
uh one for each of action indeed they're
basically
giant it's incredible yeah those are
huge
jazz nick all right all right chad is
loving it
oh
very cool totally with that grenade let
me get out of here
oh this is not good at all this is not
good at all
so what i had a question for well if
he's not too uh in
ingratiated with the action is there a
particular reason that my mech won't
listen to me like am i doing something
wrong like every time i tell it to move
it just keeps
it feels like it's going back to my base
and no matter what i tell it to
yeah you clicked on retreat
is that
how the community has been receiving
things how's the
just overall feedback towards this
project and everything
well i mean we've been working with the
backers uh since the beginning
and yeah so far they're you know they um
are really receptive
and helping us out and uh people excited
i mean
the non-backers they all over facebook
all over the social they've got ideas
they want to see something new they want
to
relive those memories
and as we're learning now there's all
these multiplayer features that we'd
like
because there's definitely the interest
there for people to you know
get up in their friend's houses and uh
stumbling with some necks
i mean he doesn't want to do it no
cognito zoom in on my stream real quick
look at this weird looking thing
oh that's nice that is nice yo this
thing's moving like
in a in a in an angle it's mad slow i i
expect this thing to like
be a nuke at this point because that's
very cool that's very cool here
well what you got what you got i ain't
showing you now
be a pal you're trying to kill me
this thing oh it's hot enough in there
in the middle
ooh okay now you're gonna make to
whatever the anti
that is but okay too fuddy
oh my lord shout out to squirrely danny
said i can't wait for this never played
hw and it's an rts light up more cc and
aoe fan but you can't wait oh that's
cool messy you're excited that's good
that's good
we love that excitement
i hate to say it man this better be good
let's go let's see what this does
oh that's that thing i was getting
killed by that yesterday
oh oh oh
okay gotta say what you gotta say oh
what is
wow i like those little things this is
now
i don't know i don't know man oh no i'm
back
that's pretty cool let's move in
nice talk to me undead
how are we feeling um i think i
i didn't completely cave once so i'm
feeling okay about it all right
undead someone on my team couldn't get
this big oil pump
i don't have any units can can the big
units take these i don't think they can
can they
they can just shoot them i don't wanna
oh there's another one of these hold up
let's all jump it let's jump it
let's start oh my god that was my gun
it was his gun oh hang on just knocking
on my front door over here what is this
[Music]
oh what is that
famous last words
come on you have to admit that was
pretty good though yeah
is there a button to to select all units
absolutely i think that's f1 or f2 f2
f2 one of the two i don't remember off
the top of my hand
it's f2 school okay school that
developer
yeah oh oh look at that it's so
beautiful those artillery
areas crazy i think oh wow wow
i ain't going that way let's go
let's go back i ain't trying to mess
with that i don't want that smoke right
now
this is too good i don't want that smoke
right now this is this is
tough man
how are you feeling petey i'm good oh oh
oh no this is
this is i walked into the wrong
neighborhood i'm getting out of here
i know you can come back man we we we're
very friendly in this one
come back when you make me a casserole
so now i'm out of here he's out
i'm out oh my god
i'm having some support my favorite mech
is a steep mutter which sends out little
rhombus
yeah yeah little wheels of death yeah i
do i saw that yeah it looked really cool
i was just
admitting those quite slow though hmm
it's a little bit deadly that's uh
pretty much a good description of saxony
in general
and very smooth yeah slow and deadly
you got it right
[Music]
oh he's got a kaiser um
i think we're in trouble fellas oh yeah
you're in trouble all right
you said build max i built max yeah
he's intoxicated by the power now look
at that look at
look at look at that fortification over
there thank you hot [ __ ]
okay let's go oh
hold up hold on this is artillery i can
just walk up to you no
you can't because i'm straight for that
ass oh no there's more
[Music]
hang on how many of these things you got
oh i got a few
i got a few man y'all gave him that
power building that he's he's learning
oh
you guys better go over there fast man
before he starts shooting me with those
uh oh i got something big and ugly
no no no no no no no no i'm just gonna
come right up in your face
for any work
all right that's one hold up something's
hitting me
yeah well you turned your back to me so
what do you expect me to do
i might lose this thing but that's all
the chat has we have some fans of a tour
mector
oh yeah that's mine here yeah hey hey
a lot of fans too yeah we're waiting for
toby we're just holding the line waiting
for toby to come over to this side of
the map
[Music]
uh
to the dev team he says the fire adam
and effects looks really good
he's a fake thank you it's time it's
time to use that retreat button
they're the famous one time to use that
retreat bug man
i destroyed a lot there i can't do that
no more
i can't lose these things like cheap man
these things are not
cheap i ain't trying to lose them
uh what is shooting at me i don't know
but it ain't me because i'm retreating
oh i see okay someone took the destroyer
cannon
where was that you ah yeah but the cabin
doesn't need to be working all the time
look in this battlefield look at the
decimation oh
that's okay hang on let me set let me
send you some help hang on
i don't know whose team you are on but
don't send them help if it's the other
team
okay sure no problem oh
elliot got something that looked crazy
[Music]
these really do look like stuff you
would see in that get that movie uh the
elite of extraordinary gentlemen
yeah yeah i've heard that before racer
dundam says attic not retreat
the correct terminology is reposition
sir
tactical withdrawal yes tactical
withdrawal
as of you use it all right squirrely did
again with the coach i don't know if
they can answer this one scrolling down
but i'll shoot he says uh
what's the target for console he was
like uh 4k30 with less bells and
whistles or 1080p 60 and more effects
i don't know if they could answer that
but i i don't think i can't answer that
yet we just
yeah we're just not there yet to be able
to answer that kind of question yet
i'm sorry that's cool if it run if it
runs well we are happy yeah
yeah you heard that there you go if it
runs well they will be pleased
yo yeah yeah stay tuned stay tuned for
soon
you know what uh sunfish hi it's help
yeah we got a problem now oh you've got
a problem that's for sure
i'll open my big slow mix you know
they're having a hard time navigating
this map you know
trying to get around one side or the
other but that's the disadvantage of
saxony
you know
yeah it's huge it's huge
we walked right into that one
looks awesome does the scorch box in the
field
stay the whole match
yes everything's destructible uh
shoot it don't let that thing run we
don't do this game
there we go look at it go all right all
right oh you pulled
it up no i'm as we going to the side
we're going to the side
those those things have to get set up no
someone says they see nazidelko in the
match okay
nice my kaiser's coming
to the front here
toby how are you doing you're very quiet
you're totally quiet uh
i'm i'm winning don't worry it's
yeah yeah toby uh had to remove his boot
and his entire leg out of my arse
i took a little what a dangerous place
i literally went from hey i'm holding my
own to three minutes later going where'd
my headquarter
did we actually witnessed in the middle
or is
they just guys pulling back to reinforce
a little bit worried
oh no they're coming to pay me a visit
so who's who
so wait so here is who's playing
polandia is it you
that would be me okay
interesting was coming up to the front
line he finally got there it's taken
about five minutes
but once it's there you know
yeah that's right turn around a little
bit for me please
capital star
i think uh it's time for everybody to
hit that f button in chat
oh i see elliot oh you're sneaking oh
that was
it was also quite funny that when your
um troop carrier died
the guys inside just jumped out and just
meleed my neck just
jumped out and punched me i'm not really
sure if they should be doing that but uh
looking for it's not very productive
you have to understand that we all know
where this game
gonna is a tactical withdrawal so elliot
is nicely demonstrating that you can
reverse mechs by holding
oh my god i'm done it's over what was
the reverse back
feature usa uh so yeah sometimes
um you need to navigate a little bit
more precisely
and you can reverse neck uh reverse the
mechs back and they do a nice little
moonwalk
and if i remember rightly it's just a
control
click if i remember or is it i think
it's a yeah hold c
right oh
i think this is it for me fellas well
you know
yeah it takes a while to get around on
the field but once you get burnt held
out then
things become old are
watch out field cannon is a mech
destroyer
absolutely absolutely true 350 percent
teamwork actually yeah actually that's a
good point let's build a few now
i don't think it'll help us right now
but
[Music]
no such luck any last words earlier uh
yeah let me talk about my hero real
quick hang on i'm not gonna do that
hang on a second let's get uncle leck
out
uh any second now
any second now hang on
come on nice
said those toys
all right hi
i need help over here just saying it's
such a good looking mech i love the
gorilla movements
just a little bit of help yeah hang on
i don't think uh i don't think help is
coming
it's a lot of people all i know is if we
win this battle i don't think you got
anything after these
this is a lot man this i got rid of one
of them
take your victories where you can't this
is
even if i lose i will take this is a
victory by itself
you still know your square attic oh
great
all right this is the last point we're
just gonna
fight till the end to the end oh
[Music]
once again no
[Music]
no playing gg gentlemen gg
good for kelly you failed me man you
you were supposed to carry us to the
promised land
and the only thing you carried me was
not to victory i'm sorry fellas but the
numbers don't lie
the numbers the numbers said that i did
best how's that
oh
double the double the combat points from
than eliot
which is funny oh my goodness shout out
this is the chance
i see saxony's hero broomhilda another
big mech
in iron harvest i gotta love the big ass
on that friend elder oh yeah
great game guys i hit those mechs of
everything i had
and what's funny is like they i saw them
the moment i saw three of those things i
was like
i i had a hard time killing off like
this much health i don't even know how
i'm gonna kill one with that much health
don't get to it don't don't ask me how i
did that but i have
my damage dealt i have more damage done
than all the three
of my opponents together
how was that how was that were you
feeding him
feeding him right i had 34 000
damage dealt and the other one is 12 12
10. i blame my loss when i'm dead he
didn't do nothing oh stop
yeah i'm dead to us
they're exposing my boy
over
a valiant effort boys oh man iron
harvest
currently right now open beta this is
fantastic let's get some feels from
everybody man
let's get a pd man now that you got a
couple matches in
how are we feeling as we getting closer
to release man about the game
it feels a lot of fun and you can
definitely see that there's so many
different elements that you have to
really get attuned to to play and be
able to know like exactly what you're
going to do like on 1v1s and you know on
especially this 3v3 that was
fantastic it was it's a lot of fun
absolutely yeah
the lord i did i know the score was a
little lower than that anticipated but
uh
from a pure fun standpoint and just
overall feeling now that you got a
couple more matches in the uh
multiplayer world hey i was second on
the team so i feel okay
i'm hella mid um but no like this is
the thing that really impressed me this
game front to back and even when
uh the previous or whatever you wanna
call the last demo
period that this game had um the amount
of polish
this game has and the fact it's not even
out yet
is is phenomenal um because i run on a
potato pc and this thing runs
beautifully
like absolutely beautifully and i
absolutely love it
front to back this will be a day one for
me
nice yeah thank
and there's there's absolutely more to
come after launch as well
this is just the beginning awesome
nice and addicts above father was you
your thoughts now you got a couple
matches in little skirmishes little
multiplayer
how we feeling overall about iron
harvest i'm scared of mex now
but uh you know i i i really feel the
aesthetics of the game
like cause it gives me that like leave
extraordinary gentleman five
um there's not many rts's that even come
to console so the fact that this is
going to
go up on consoles nice and then there's
not many that have 3v3 to the
aspect that i think that game's gonna
have the only thing you know
whenever you guys were able to put that
ping system and stuff in and
i think it would be a solid experience
on consoles especially
no doubt and absolutely we'll end off
with the dev team and
i'm sorry here is going there
and down look violet i saw you in there
i saw a ghost
you in there go in there and download
this demo man like go play
just put the steam link in the chat like
i said guys check it out
enjoy it having a lot of fun i'll leave
with the dev team just again
your thoughts anything you want to tell
the people as we close it as well as
well as toby
uh well i would i would quit if i can so
william do you want to start let me be
the last one sure uh
thoughts uh world jack is life boyjack
is love
um he's a little bear character we've
got going and campaign you'll learn all
about him
um so yeah people who you know love
multiplayer but also
like to take time to themselves in these
corona times yeah this is the game for
you
and um it's a game for me that's that's
kind of what i love about it
awesome awesome they agree the chat says
they're downloading the game now it
looks
awesome i'm seeing diesel punk diesel
pumped in the chat a bunch of times
people are really excited and uh
all right um i think i'll first start
off with as an rts fan myself
i want to thank every single rts fan so
far that has
trusted us to make this game what
it is right now and what we want it to
be in the future um
hop on to the beta let us know what your
thoughts are and
uh yeah more to come soon awesome you
know what's funny there at the very end
when i saw on the other side of me i saw
the yellow showing up
i thought that was ellie and i thought
he was there to be in my rescuer
no it was it was it was another enemy
[Laughter]
toby back in the driver's seat again
iron harvest great showing it wasn't
much of an iron challenge but uh
oh no it was really really really good
actually
right so i want to thank everyone i want
to thank the iron lords of course for
making this possible
thank you that we could have uh that
that we can be guests on your stream
that we can play together that you that
you share the law for me it's nice to be
back in the trenches with
this new project and i want to i'm
really looking forward to see how
the people in the beta are doing so far
i must say i'm very happy with the lobby
being filled when you click on quick
match it's
really a question of seconds and then
you are connected
it's pretty cool everyone is still in
the learning phase so it's
you most likely won't meet like the
super pros of course that's always
possible but
i'm just saying that you can still
[Music]
be successful be very successful in the
game so go and try it for sure
and overall uh yeah thank you for having
us and i'm really looking forward to see
what the people say
and absolutely i hope that corona and
everything that health and everyone is
getting
good again as soon as possible i hope
that no one has
too much harm and then of course i'm
also also looking to
meet you guys live again yeah and we get
to see once the once the world gets back
to a little bit
of normalcy we'll definitely read again
and again it's always a pleasure you
know doing this thing again thank you
guys for the dev team
thank you so much for having us oh much
appreciate this was fun
you guys are great the game looks great
i'm excited about it our base is excited
about it
and it's like everyone's saying that
they said it best very polished very
cool
laura is awesome diesel punk is awesome
alive and well
that's all i got so uh we gonna sign out
and uh leave you guys with this great
music that you've been listening back
and uh everybody enjoy
your saturday we are out of here iron
harvest dev team thank you again iron
lord salute
and of course the lords of gaming gaming
addict lord petey sneldo and
undead from lords of gaming.net for
today's
action everybody enjoy your saturday we
are